sì certo che cazzo successo
e vabbè programmiamo l'ho pure aspetta
che inizia a programmare bella a tutti
ragazzi via merito in questo nuovo video
sono fatti j
oggi siamo su kate mario che è un video
genere non è che mario grazie a dio
click
forse lo so è che comunque lo so che non
lo sa nessuno che in realtà queste prove
lo dico io è quindi dare un gioco dove
c'è del sangue
ecco peccato l'unico livello della non
c'è il sangue volta di culo clic su
start è un lia col mouse ragazzi da
quando è uscito il mouse su itunes si
sono rincoglionito tutti cioè è cambiato
in una maniera pazzesca da quando c'è il
mouse non so come mai come cazzo le
attivit box boost buste della spesa per
morto ma dovevo costruire il ponte 12
conte qua chi è adesso devo farmi
mettere la punta nel culo non erano non
ci credo torna su ma cava dove a casa ma
dov'è
ma manco un mago professionista facciamo
sparire così a parla mai mai mai mai ce
l'abbiamo fatto ragazzi cielo sì ma stai
calmo questo mi stimi mi fa saltare
direttamente al è la madonna
che figo ragazzi già state questo è
amico di challant appello che però
facciamo lo stesso just 2 ho capito non
so sciaia lavoro
ha citofonato credo che sia arrivato il
corriere con le medaglie ragazzi save
your family mi mancava save your family
come [ __ ] adesso questa mela
spiegate serio non è serio devi farti un
giro modo [ __ ] però salvato
l'ananas è già qualcosa ragazzi prendi
questa birra nipote bevi della birra che
fa bene io l'atleta l'avevo già avevo
già scopato ognun dialisi sila che cazzo
sta facendo luke spiegatemelo qual è il
tuo problema di di vita non inclinare la
testa per mirare inclina proprio tutta
l'arma senza guardare così giustamente
ex come fate che prendo la bottiglia e
basta
no veramente ho compreso solo lui è la
bottiglia è rimasta in terra l'esatto
opposto di quello che ho detto perfetto
non farò mai tiro a bersaglio ragazze
rischierei di ammazzare persone al
contagio ho vinto
no per ci posso credere mai chi sta che
adesso adesso mi girano le palle ti
stacchi e mentre ti trascini come ho
fatto a perth ma non è possibile mai una
ragazza impossibile sto livello si sa
chi sono io sono io sono riuscita a
farmi cadere il poco sullo stomaco
perfetto mi fa un po di spazio grazie
avanti che avanti più mi stai prendendo
per il culo
allora ok no bene ma che cazzo fazio di
trascinarlo ce l'ha fatta grazie al 6 su
12 anni per fare un livello de merda
lasciamo perdere a little world no va
beh scusate la canna non volevo
uccidermi siete così carini perché
ragazzi sembra l'attacco dei giganti
stanno ci sono anche le mura oddio sta
facendo la cosa fa no non è cosa sta
succedendo calmi stai calmo stai calmo
gigante nella mission mago merlino armi
chiama messo la barriera di ghiaccio
mi piace zio ma così mi sembri più e
mago forest kingdom
oddio c'è il regno di gla ragazzi
fantastico una capra un lupo che ha
scortato un tizio raga qualcuno mi
spiega il senso di sto livello ci sono
ma perché sono più grossi degli esseri
umani l'impossible jump
e va bene che cos'è la madonna bello non
sono io sono bravo a queste cose
no ragazzi non si può fare impossibile
come faccio a non è possibile entrarci
sto coso non si può come si fa a fare
stato sì o disney live aid proviamo a
questo ragazzo
insomma e vabbè mi sono staccato un
braccio all'inizio
cosa devo fare la devo tutto e la
madonna si va bene non si può fare una
cosa impossibile che mi stai chiedendo
veramente invece si è invece si dice
contrario
va bene quanta roba ragazzi quanta
quanta roba o rimbalzato con la schiena
che ove cazzo è possibile addio c'è
sceglie lavoro fly si sta guardando il
suo figlio ma che cazzo c'entra bene
ragazzi diventato un video su child
alive sta guardando un suo film sto
cristiano e commentiamo dai che a
sorrisi e la madonna tabitha b2k 16
clinic dow chemical più cazzuto non lo
potevi mettere ciano no a posto
bello no serie a dopo a dovevo prenderlo
buttano giocate bastardo lui è andato
giù pero si è salvato solo lui e l'altro
magari le spine nella arbitro hai visto
però è vero rischio di 21 hanno voluto
oggi sky ha venti hanno fatta ce l'ho
fatta attrazioni della morte va bene che
tra l'altro in attrazione con con eddy e
nono ciak
oddio redditi no no re gt1 bravo zio
bravo zio e zia
adesso la morte mi spiace stranzi io
sono rimasto vi è anche nonno ciak è
morta adesso morti tutti se magari mi
lascio andare brio
scusa frate non volevo tirato uno
schiaffo è solo che sono caduto così
avremo kamasutra sitra qualche altra web
come l'hai scritto giustizia to my 3d
level it took mia long time to black
list ed anche my friends ab affanculo si
sa sono è un altro youtube oddio figlia
sono partito il cuore calmo miss e lì
non ho più sellino ma [ __ ]
per chuck norris caracca zio o perfetto
santo dio e la stessa difficoltà che ho
a entrare in classe e lunedì mattina
ragazzi stessa roba make your music di
chiamarti ingari e fini il gioco di
merda ma ci gioco anche a merenda escape
from prison devo scappare la prigione
tipo michael scofield your arresto e
foreste vende freezone rifletto skip
conversation che è di tua moglie ti ha
portato una torta per il tuo compleanno
grazie adesso prendo la torta crixus
quella [ __ ] si è resa utile gravati
da cazzo tu e tutta la puglia
ok stavo scherzando
ok ok perfetto ho già fatta ce l'ho
fatta l'aj scappa scappa lo ri doppio no
sociali
voglio aiutarti l'uscita da questa parte
grazie zio a gentile brutto figlio di
[ __ ] ragazzi spiegate mi sono fatta
apri però se non ce l'ha
[Musica]
fra i manager ora puoi prendere a poi
tornare con tua moglie grazie ai ragazzi
facciamo un paio di miei livelli come al
solito alla fine poi centra nel box so
che ce la puoi fare continuo sia un
grande e viva fa vj ma vj per parigi
ma veramente era una presa per il culo
ci sono riuscito su serricoli j
all'inferno 2 godetevi la discesa verso
gli inferi sapete che ci troverete non
so chi vai dio che cazzo c'entra non lo
sa che da quando non sa che dio
purgatorio dove scontare la pena ragazzi
no non c'entra il purgatorio solo per
gli hub che io sappia rosso
velato di ragazzi sto scappando da
satana sono fa vigenti classes non solo
per questo hai vinto la vita solo per
questo ai pango 95 favi ci prova questo
madonna zio ho vinto sinora questo è
meno male che non c'erano i porno
cosa è successo fermi non ho neanche
visto va bene va bene ho vinto sulla
fiducia va bene perché sono ragazzi che
proprio non mi piace questo livello e
merita mi piace sto livello non si è
capito un cazzo ma va bene bravo zio
complimenti per aver fatto il livello
della vita era l'emozione come hobby
l'episodio di è primis costo finale
assurdo perché non ha senso
vedrai che spero che vi sia piaciuto
questo evento il centro subito che mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook e
comuni video trovate la descrizione
senza vestiti skater ci vediamo al
prossimo video italia